sound the trumpets because it's little
archie's second birthday
i would say i'm just really thrilled
meghan markle and prince harry's
adorable son turned
two years old on thursday and even
though he's an
ocean away from his extended family in
the uk the birthday boy still received a
ton
of love the official royal family
account which represents queen elizabeth
ii
shared a sweet family pic of harry and
megan with their newborn son
at windsor castle writing quote wishing
archie mountbatten windsor
a very happy second birthday it's
magic it's pretty amazing and i mean i
have the two
best guys in the world so i'm really
happy on the clarence house instagram
account
prince charles and duchess camilla
shared a black and white portrait with
his son prince harry
and his grandson archie at his private
christening
as for prince william and kate middleton
they posted a group
shot from the same event and sent their
birthday wishes in the caption
meanwhile megan and harry's non-profit
organization
archwell used their little boy's
birthday to advocate for covid19 vaccine
equity
writing on their website quote we will
not be able to truly recover until
everyone everywhere has equal access to
the vaccine
and with that intention we are inviting
you to contribute whatever you can
if you have the means to do so to bring
vaccines to families in the world's most
vulnerable places
the posts come amid ongoing tension
between the royal family and the duke
and duchess of sussex
the couple made the decision to step
down as senior members of the royal
family in 2020
a decision that became official earlier
this year
then in march the couple sat down for a
tell-all interview with oprah winfrey
where they discussed an alleged
conversation between harry and a senior
member of the royal family
who according to the couple expressed
quote concerns about how dark archie's
skin might be when he was born
while they were braced for for something
explosive they totally underestimated
just how far harry and megan would go
the couple declined to identify
who allegedly made those statements but
oprah later revealed that harry told her
that it was neither the queen
nor prince philip the talk at the palace
is that they
are absolutely horrified by what has
been said they feel that
harry has literally thrown the family
under a bus
but now things seem to be smoothing over
slowly
but surely harry reunited with his
family last month for his grandfather
prince philip's funeral
i know that prince harry was very
nervous ahead of coming over to the uk
for the funeral of course this was the
first time he had seen members of his
family
in over a year and i think it very much
was the case that he
got the cold shoulder from some members
of the family not his father
not his brother and not the duchess of
cambridge and despite some reports that
interactions with his family were cold
the source tells e.t he welcomed the
opportunity to reconnect
especially since kovid has prevented him
and his wife meghan markle
who's pregnant with the couple's second
child from traveling to the uk
over the last year things were not going
to be resolved in
one or two family meetings so while this
has been an
important step there's clearly still a
lot of hurt
a lot of resentment and a degree of
mistrust
i think on both parts e.t source also
says harry and william have been working
on the commemoration to their mother
princess diana
scheduled for later this summer on what
would have been her 60th birthday in
july
the source says that while relationships
were quote raw in the aftermath of the
oprah interview
both brothers quote remain fully
committed to carrying on diana's legacy
jointly
it's early days but i think the hope is
that come july when we are hoping to see
the brothers
stand once again shoulder by shoulder to
unveil
the statue in memory of their mother
that the relationship will be
stronger and in a better place
you